all right how many rats would it take to  overwhelm and kill you in a fight  oh i would say  two  i don't think i'll hurry i wouldn't fare  well with rats i mean i feel like one  time i did have a mouse running up my  hallway and like i was in front of the  door and i just kicked it like andy moog  and it went flying and died  so  one i could handle i think probably two  rats would [ __ ] me up  i just feel like i wouldn't do well with  the wraps  i went with andy mug i should have said  reggie lemlin or someone more recent  would you rather have to watch sports or  porn upside down for the rest of your  life i guess i'd do porn porn works i'm  a bit i like sports way more than i like  porn  because i'm old um  i'm gonna take i'll take porn upside  down that seems fun